Moscow is being accused of weaponizing
winter as it targets Ukraine's energy
facilities the bidences strikes knocked
out Power and Water Supplies in the cave
region more than three million people
have been without Heating in Sub-Zero
temperatures power outages have also
affected other regions this stretch from
kharkiv in the north to live in the west
as well as the Odessa region in the
South Ukraine's state-run energy firm
says three nuclear plants have switched
off supply to the Energy electrical grid
and as when it progresses temperatures
are predicted to plummet to as low as
-20 degrees in some areas the who says
up to 3 million people could flee their
homes in search of warmth and safety
where we challenges more from the
Ukrainian city of viscerod
I think there's one word for the
condition in Ukraine at the moment and
that is miserable there are millions of
people across the country who have spent
the night in cold damp chilly apartments
and homes with no power and no running
water this is fish garage on the
outskirts of the capital Kiev and this
is a place that yesterday was targeted
by a Russian missile it destroyed an
apartment building here killing five
people just up the roads there is also a
power plant so presumably the Russians
were aiming for that but they missed and
instead they got an apartment building
now emergency services have set up a
tent here to help people in the area and
this is where you can come if you want a
bit of warmth and something hot to eat
we can speak to aliona here who's an
emergency services worker Aliana what is
this place what's going on here
hi it's our Invincible Point people
comes here to
drink some tea or coffee maybe eat some
cookie to spend the time in a warm place
and to charge the phones you can you can
come inside let's go and have a look
okay so let's draw the camera and going
first it's a little cramped in there
so apologies if the the lens fogs up a
bit here but as you can see conditions
are kind of basic but you know it's warm
and there is power there's somewhere to
lie down there's a hot drink and that's
what people need at the moment so in the
moment there is still 70 percent of Kiev
that is without power though the mayor
Vitali Klitschko says that emergency
services have been working throughout
the night to try and get power back up
for the city there has been water
restored on the Left Bank of the city
but still on the right Bank it remains
powerless
um there is something else I want to
show you here which is uh a rabbit
in a box
this was found bouncing around on the
streets presumably from the destroyed
building and the emergency service here
is saying that they are finding animals
like this and when they do find them
they bring them to this invincibility
point and the owners when they can can
come and collect them